법인으로 매입했을 때 취득세가
증가됩니다 원래는 4.6% 99.4%
Pro 취득세 증가가
[음악]
됩니다네 안녕세요 빌사남 있니다
법인으로 부동산 투자하는 이유에
대해서 좀 설명을 드리겠습니다
법인으로 투자하는 이유는 두 가지
장점 때문에 어 투자를 하는데요 첫
번째는 대출 때문에 어 투자를 합니다
보통 법인으로 매입하면 rti 적용을
받지 않아요 그래서 임대 수익이 안
나오는 건물도 법인으로 매입했을 때는
어 대출이 나옵니다 개인으로 대출받기
좀 어려우셨던 분들이 법인을 설립해서
어 많이 매입한다고 좀 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그리고 또 많은 분들이 또
오해하시는게 신규법인 같은 경우에는
대출이 안 나온다 뭐 이렇게 알고
계신 분이 계시는데 신규 법인도
대출이 나옵니다 다만 금리가 조금
높거나 아니면 한도가 조금 작을 수도
있습니다 그리고 신규법인 같은
경우에는 대표자 신용을 좀 많이
봅니다 대표자가 신용 상태라든지
아무래도 재무제표가 없다 보니까
대표자 신용을 좀 많이 본다라는 거
알고 계시면 될 거 같고요 그 두
번째로는 세금 부분입니다 법인으로
매입했을 때 한 가지 근데 주의해야
될 점은 설립된지 5년 미만이고
과밀억제권역내 본점이 있고
과밀억제권역내 부동산을 취득하게 되면
취득세가 증가됩니다 원래는 4.6%
99.4% 취득세 증가가 됩니다이
증가된 부분은 어찌됐든 취득 가액에
포함되기 때문에 기분은 좋지 않지만
어 세금을 먼저 냈다 어 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같습니다 개인 같은
경우에는 내가 만약에 38%
구간이다라고 하면 임대 수익이란 같이
합상 가세 됩니다 그래서 세금 부담이
굉장히 커지고 건강 보험료도 올라갈
수 있습니다 근데 법인 같은 경우에는
뭐이자 빼고 못 빼고 다 하면은 과세
표준이 대부분 다 2억
미만이거나 안 되는 그런 세율 부담을
하신다고 보시면 됩니다 그리고
마지막으로 양도 소득세가 제일 큰데
개인 같은 경우에 정도 차액이 만약에
10억이다라고 하면 세금이 무려
지방소득세가 49.5% 부 부과가
됩니다 근데 법인 같은 경우에는 약
21% 정도 부담을 하신다고 보시면
됩니다 법인 투자할 때이 양도 소득세
때문에 설립해 하시는 분들이 좀 많이
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요 그리고
마지막으로 좀 참고사항 말씀드리면
내가 만약 현금이 10억이 있다라고
하면 10억짜리 법인을 설립하면 안
됩니다 나중에 10억을 빼기 어려워요
그래서 보통 어떻게 하냐면 자본금 한
1억짜리 법인을 설립한 다음에
99억을 이제 대여합니다 그래서
나중에 이제 뭐 차액이 발생되거나
돈을 좀 급하게 빼야 될 경우가
생겼을 때 그 대여한 금액은 세금
없이 뺄 수 있어요 왜냐면 내가
대어야 한 거기 때문에 그래서 보통은
자본금이 큰 회사를 설립하지 않고
은행에서 조금 증자 요청을 할 수도
있어요 자본금은 최대한 적게 설립을
합니다 더 나아가서는 자녀들이 만약에
있다 징역까지 생각하신다고 하면은
그때 이제 법인 설립할 때부터 증여를
같이 해 가지고 주주로 같이 참여를
시킵니다 부동산
투자함으로써 신규법인 투자를 하고
싶다라고 하시면 어이 영상을
참고하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘
법인 투자 관련돼서 좀 설명을
드렸고요 어 신규법인 투자를 하실
분들이 참고하실 만한 어 내용으로 좀
준비했습니다 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]